hi in this video we are going to learn
about substrate level phosphorylation so
let's look at what is substrate level
phosphorylation so when the phosphate
group of a substrate is transferred to
the 18 ADP in order to make ATP is
called a substrate level phosphorylation
so the key important part here is the
phosphate group which is actually
derived from a substrate is added on to
ADP and as a result ATP is produced so
this is an important concept and in case
of glycolysis this is the key mechanism
by which ATP is generated so let's look
at the glycolysis process in a bit more
details so this is the glycolysis steps
so you can see here there are two steps
where ATP is generated and this is also
known as the payoff phase and there is
the investment phase as well in the
payoff phase where the ATP is generated
you can see that phosphate which is
attached to adp comes from a substrate
in the first reaction in the first
reaction where 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
is converted to 3 phosphoglycerate in
that situation one of these phosphate
group is transferred to the adp in order
to make ATP and in case of
phosphoenolpyruvate to pyruvate control
conversion the first the phosphate group
is added to adp and ultimately it
generates ATP so let's look at this
process in a bit more details
so let's first draw the structure of 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate so we draw the
structure of 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
so the 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate structure
is somewhere like this so in the third
position and in the second position
there is a phosphate group right so this
is the first carbon this is the third
carbon so there is two phosphate groups
here right ultimately what is going to
happen is this phosphate groups are
going to be transferred on ADP right so
two reactions are happening
simultaneously here ADP is actually
going to be converted to ATP and the
phosphate which is going to be acquired
in order to make ATP comes from 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate and this 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate is one of the
substrate for glycolysis that is where
is also known as substrate level
phosphorylation and what it would
produce after making ATP now after the
next intermediate it would produce 3
phosphoglycerate which somewhat looks
like this so here the phosphate group is
taken away and in the third position the
phosphate group is in that so this
structure is now known as 3
phosphoglycerate so this is one of the
reaction of the substrate level
phosphorylation and let's talk about the
next reaction or the next step of it so
the next step is actually conversion of
phosphoenolpyruvate
to pyruvate I mean this is the last step
of the glycolysis pathway now in this
process let's look at the structure as
well just to get a better understanding
so here is a structure of the
phosphoenolpyruvate so the
phosphoenolpyruvate is in an all so you
can see here this is the N part and this
is the all phosphoenolpyruvate and it is
ultimately getting converted into
pyruvate and the phosphate group is
taken away taken away by phil taken away
by ATP in order to generate adp right 80
ATP is produced but ADP is taking the
phosphate group sorry for that but it
ADP is taking the phosphate group
ultimately it is generating ATP and this
phosphate group by which the ATP is
produced it comes from
phosphoenolpyruvate which is another
substrate for glycolysis pathway and
that is why these two steps are known as
substrate level phosphorylation and
substrate level phosphorylation later we
would discuss is a key mechanism by
which ATP is generated especially cancer
cells and the stem cells use this
mechanism for their energy purposes and
they don't prefer other pathways like
Krebs cycle or a respiration or ox force
pathway to generate energy this only
depends are dependent on glycolytic
pathways so we'll talk about that later
so if you liked this video give a thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you